Caption: big round of applause for Michelle okay
Caption: it is working is it working yes all
Caption: right
Caption: hello Perth thank you for having me this
Caption: is fantastic
Caption: I am from Melbourne and before I flew in
Caption: here I
Caption: yesterday morning went to see a talk by
Caption: brené Brown if you don't know who brené
Caption: Brown is she has her own Netflix special
Caption: for example and if you have even the
Caption: tiniest bit of impostor syndrome I
Caption: suggest you don't watch one of the top
Caption: ten speakers the day before you're going
Caption: to do your own talk the other thing that
Caption: fills me with joy and confidence
Caption: there is another talk by Michelle
Caption: Sanford about robots and in my original
Caption: intro I was practicing on my husband and
Caption: I said if you if you're in the looking
Caption: for the Michelle talked about the robots
Caption: taking over the world you're in the
Caption: wrong room and he got up off the couch
Caption: and went where are the robots I was like
Caption: thanks honey this is great so thank you
Caption: all for coming to my talk I am gonna
Caption: talk about what to do when you are
Caption: working on agile who is working on agile
Caption: I assume everybody cuz nobody admits to
Caption: doing anything else anymore it's like
Caption: I'm a job yeah me too
Caption: we're we're really agile yeah us too so
Caption: it's what to do when you're working on
Caption: agile projects and your manager says as
Caption: mine did once you know oh when will it
Caption: be done yet and is it done yet and how
Caption: about now and then it kind of goes in
Caption: this cycle when will it be done is it
Caption: done yet how about no when will it be
Caption: done which turns into a little bit of a
Caption: death spiral and as promised I do have a
Caption: magic crystal ball which I used but
Caption: first of all I would like to thank all
Caption: of these awesome sponsors because they
Caption: helped make this conference affordable
Caption: for all of us
Caption: shameless plug for yow
Caption: because we are also an awesome
Caption: conference giving away free tickets last
Caption: chance to enter blah blah and I would
Caption: also like to thank the volunteers
Caption: because you have put in so much work I
Caption: have seen I know how running a
Caption: conference is and you absolutely blow me
Caption: away so thank you all the volunteers for
Caption: this conference because it doesn't go
Caption: very excited for me I was here as a kind
Caption: of a hoverer last year so it's exciting
Caption: to make it to speak so once upon a time
Caption: when Angela and I were both much younger
Caption: I worked on a team as you do and we were
Caption: working supposedly a job as as tends to
Caption: happen and despite the fact that we were
Caption: supposedly agile we still had these
Caption: wretched deadlines and you know we'd be
Caption: working weekends and and nights and it
Caption: was just a god-awful mess and at the
Caption: same time I was reading about you know
Caption: agile sustainable pace and I'm thinking
Caption: you know what real edge all wet places
Caption: don't have deadlines we just doing this
Caption: wrong this is rubbish if only I was at
Caption: one of those real agile places that
Caption: would be fantastic and then I left that
Caption: company and I went to work at a real
Caption: agile place which made products and was
Caption: really product centric and was
Caption: everything I'd even read about and um
Caption: yeah we still had deadlines and I
Caption: thought alright okay what's what's going
Caption: on here what's up with this and the
Caption: thing is in our case I was working at
Caption: zero and we had government legislation
Caption: you know guess what the ATO is not going
Caption: to move the end of the tax year for you
Caption: because your projects a little bit late
Caption: so a couple of the things I was working
Caption: on was making text digital which is a
Caption: project in the UK
Caption: HMRC which is their equivalent of the
Caption: ATO
Caption: we were working on a project for that
Caption: implementing that at zero and also
Caption: simple abbess which was another hgo
Caption: project but hey you know maybe there's
Caption: another kind of deadline again
Caption: Australian Open date they're not going
Caption: to shift it just because the websites
Caption: not ready so you know or maybe your
Caption: company and
Caption: company are kind of in a little bit of a
Caption: race to put something out first you know
Caption: zero and where would be one of them put
Caption: something out the other ones like oh
Caption: yeah well we'll get there first
Caption: so that might be a reason you're trying
Caption: to put thing something up before a
Caption: certain date people another date that's
Caption: not going to shift no one's going to
Caption: move their birth delivery date of their
Caption: child because they have a thing that
Caption: they need to work on so you might need
Caption: to you know adhere to that deadline
Caption: another example might be you've made
Caption: this wonderful proclamation so again at
Caption: zero they have these enormous
Caption: conferences called zero con where
Caption: somebody stands up and says we are going
Caption: to deliver this amazing thing by the
Caption: first quarter and you really want to
Caption: actually be able to do that because if
Caption: you don't you kind of end up with
Caption: something like this so this is a site
Caption: called Ellen musk today and it's
Caption: entirely devoted to tracking all the
Caption: promises mr. musk has made on Twitter
Caption: and how he's kind of tracking to that
Caption: you know spoiler alert
Caption: generally not so good so you know I mean
Caption: this is this is a bit of a joke right
Caption: this is slightly exaggerated but I found
Caption: hell hath no fury like a customer
Caption: scorned so you really you really don't
Caption: want to do that so where did this
Caption: impression come from if you tweeted the
Caption: first one to show that I'm a
Caption: you can tweet this one now and say yeah
Caption: no I don't think that's really the case
Caption: that's kind of what I thought it's not
Caption: in the agile manifesto they do talk
Caption: about sustainable peace but they don't
Caption: say we value not having deadlines right
Caption: so I'm thinking there's probably a
Caption: couple of reasons why younger more naive
Caption: me had this impression and the first one
Caption: is a lot of times we talk about
Caption: companies that are doing it right or
Caption: doing it good has anybody heard of the
Caption: Spotify model you know Spotify Facebook
Caption: Google Twitter Netflix you know these
Caption: are all companies that held up as being
Caption: these are the great places to work right
Caption: but I don't know about you and maybe I
Caption: missed the memo but I don't ever hear
Caption: Facebook saying we're bringing you this
Caption: awesome new feature next three
Caption: stay you're just logging in and it's
Caption: like - ah what just happened Google
Caption: sometimes gives you the ability to swap
Caption: in or out Google Calendar I'm looking at
Caption: you they've brought up the new version
Caption: of calendar and they still let you go
Caption: back to the old one which was just as
Caption: well because all the stuff that was in
Caption: the old one wasn't really in the new one
Caption: yet when they first brought it out so
Caption: you kind of had to go back to the old
Caption: one YouTube still has some of that but
Caption: sometimes you just get what you get and
Caption: you can't swap back and then you get
Caption: things like this so probably most people
Caption: know Ming I was in the middle of writing
Caption: this talk and Ming kindly put this on
Caption: LinkedIn as an example of the sort of
Caption: feeling that you have is user when
Caption: you're merrily using your product in
Caption: which case Facebook and they make a
Caption: small change and she was a little bit
Caption: displeased with that ah yeah so the
Caption: other thing that people associate with
Caption: with deadlines is is this guy I don't
Caption: know if everybody seen the movie office
Caption: space it's kind of required viewing for
Caption: people in our industry and even the word
Caption: deadline people just have this like that
Caption: as soon as you say deadline you're like
Caption: oh that's it my life is over
Caption: so we end up calling things milestones
Caption: and goals and things that are a little
Caption: bit less horrifying because as soon as
Caption: you say deadlines people just think this
Caption: guy's gonna show up and tell you that
Caption: you're just gonna go I have to ask you
Caption: to go ahead and come in and Saturday and
Caption: Sunday and there goes your weekend in
Caption: your life and you'll sleep and as in the
Caption: previous talk it's burnout city and you
Caption: just hope that if only we did this agile
Caption: think properly all this horror would
Caption: disappear another thing I saw on
Caption: LinkedIn from Josh Pataki who's a scrum
Caption: coach I think he's sometimes around poof
Caption: and somehow he ends up always putting
Caption: something on social media around about
Caption: at the time I'm doing a talk side
Caption: he's a feature of my talks for some
Caption: reason so he's got this manifesto for
Caption: deadline driven development we're
Caption: uncovering better ways of developing
Caption: software by doing lots of over
Caption: and you know possibly forcing others to
Caption: do it right but does it have to be like
Caption: this I mean if we if we're taking it as
Caption: a given that sometimes deadlines happen
Caption: for reasons there must be some other way
Caption: we can cope apart from turning into the
Caption: guy telling you you have to come in and
Caption: and having these horrible manifestos we
Caption: want to avoid the death march and the
Caption: mini waterfall horror so what I'm going
Caption: to try and do in the next few minutes is
Caption: to give you some ideas of things that we
Caption: had tried and that kind of helped with
Caption: this obviously the answer is because if
Caption: only we did this right then everything
Caption: would be fine
Caption: you know come on we just need to get
Caption: better at estimating has anybody ever
Caption: heard anybody say this and the first
Caption: time I heard that I thought wow okay you
Caption: know we could spend a whole lot of time
Caption: improving anything and really this is
Caption: what you want to spend the time and
Caption: effort on you know to a lot of people
Caption: when you say estimate where there's an
Caption: estimate there's an actual identify
Caption: manager I get to compare them and then I
Caption: get to say well are you really not very
Caption: good at estimating because look at the
Caption: difference between your estimates in
Caption: your actuals do better but you know is
Caption: that is really is that what we want to
Caption: spend our time on I question this so in
Caption: there's a book called lean software
Caption: development which maybe some people have
Caption: heard of was written by the pop index
Caption: Mary and Tom pop and dick and this is
Caption: what they have to say about waste so
Caption: it's anything that doesn't add value to
Caption: a product and the value is determined by
Caption: the customer so I don't know about you
Caption: as customers I know certainly when I get
Caption: a product I don't go well you know it's
Caption: all right but I wish they've done a
Caption: better job estimating I mean customers
Caption: can't see that stuff
Caption: so if I look at this definition time
Caption: spent estimating is by definition a
Caption: waste right and it should be minimized
Caption: with the goal of trying to eliminate it
Caption: rather than spending time getting better
Caption: because if you're spending time on it to
Caption: try and improve that kind of increases
Caption: the waste
Caption: I'm not gonna say hashtag no estimates
Caption: don't ever do that
Caption: it summons trolls if you do that on
Caption: social media I am not joking there's a
Caption: group of people in Melbourne we were
Caption: setting up agile drinks and it was like
Caption: what time do you think you're going to
Caption: be there and their comment was I'm not
Caption: really sure hashtag no estimates haha
Caption: boom here comes the guy well you know
Caption: he's trolling a pub conversation wow
Caption: these people are intense what I will say
Caption: is to try and spend less time on
Caption: estimating not more okay fine I who say
Caption: that sounds good
Caption: but we still need a way to know when
Caption: will it be done and are you done yet
Caption: so alright alternatives please what we
Caption: want to try and do is to make our work
Caption: as simple transparent and predictable as
Caption: possible okay sounds logical so
Caption: predictable this is a quote from Neil
Caption: Killick and he says that predictability
Caption: is improved by behaving and delivering
Caption: more predictably not by getting better
Caption: at making predictions right so probably
Caption: people have heard this kind of thing
Caption: before we want to try and put something
Caption: valuable into the hands of users belly
Caption: on get some feedback and try and do it
Caption: on a regular basis you know hello scrum
Caption: probably a lot of people have seen this
Caption: drawing before as well if you haven't
Caption: seen it it's from Henrik Nyberg and I'm
Caption: gonna relate it to deadlines so if
Caption: you're assuming that what you're trying
Caption: to do is get somewhere faster than
Caption: walking right I can quickly give you a
Caption: skateboard and say here you go
Caption: this would be some way faster than
Caption: walking and as a customer you might go
Caption: well kind of like the wheels but it's a
Caption: bit wobbly and to be honest it's not
Caption: really that much less effort then it was
Caption: when I was walking a little bit faster
Caption: so then you can say alright here's a
Caption: scooter and so forth and so on
Caption: now what the person or your customer
Caption: might have been thinking of is what I
Caption: really want is a car okay
Caption: but imagine if you're trucking along and
Caption: you hit a deadline kind of here
Caption: now if if I was going straight for the
Caption: car when I get to that point you know
Caption: and it's C aton date or whatever you
Caption: have to ship if I'm going straight for
Caption: the car I've got two wheels and some
Caption: sort of axle which is not very helpful
Caption: if I'm going with the bottom one at
Caption: least I have a bike so I would say the
Caption: bottom one is going to work better when
Caption: you're when you're faced with a deadline
Caption: okay so you're trying to have something
Caption: useful along the way rather than going
Caption: straight for the gold standard which
Caption: also sounds good in theory it's lovely
Caption: picture but how do you actually do this
Caption: kind of thing so my first recommendation
Caption: is story mapping has everybody heard of
Caption: story mapping before or a few people
Caption: there's a book by Jeff pattern called
Caption: user story mapping which I didn't bother
Caption: with for quite a long time because I
Caption: thought that doesn't sound very
Caption: interesting so I will try and resell it
Caption: to you as everything you ever wanted to
Caption: know about doing anything with stories
Caption: or developing ever because there's a
Caption: whole bunch of stuff in there that's
Caption: really really helpful so the idea of a
Caption: story map is as it sort of sounds it's a
Caption: map of a story so you start from one
Caption: side over here and it's what users will
Caption: do with your system or your product
Caption: going across and it's written in plain
Caption: English words know kind of techno jargon
Caption: across the top is the major activities
Caption: that can be broken down and underneath
Caption: each one is what it can be broken down
Caption: into so the example that Jeff uses in
Caption: the book is if I'm doing a map of
Caption: getting ready to go to work in the
Caption: morning and this is a great exercise a
Caption: typical kind of workshop thing you can
Caption: do when you're practicing this one of
Caption: the things across the top might be I'm
Caption: getting cleaned up and that might break
Caption: down into these short verb phrases
Caption: things like have a shower do my hair
Caption: shave put on makeup you know another one
Caption: might be get dressed and you might go
Caption: through all the different garments and
Caption: different things people different people
Caption: will do different things but it's
Caption: something that's quite easy to
Caption: understand and easy to explain to
Caption: somebody what it's
Caption: how it works so if we're looking at
Caption: something that's simple it's a pretty
Caption: simple concept it's like so many things
Caption: that are simple doesn't mean it's easy
Caption: and if you put this thing up on a wall
Caption: like you can see here it's also pretty
Caption: transparent right anybody can walk past
Caption: there what are you working on it's like
Caption: ah is this thing I prepared earlier and
Caption: it's quite easy to explain to them what
Caption: you're doing and how it relates to a
Caption: customer so that's another part of this
Caption: it's it's very customer focused when you
Caption: build this and as you iterate through it
Caption: so breaking it down when you have your
Caption: map laid out so if you've got your big
Caption: story at the top and then you've got
Caption: your smaller stories lined up underneath
Caption: you can literally draw a line underneath
Caption: a part of it that relates to a goal that
Caption: can be completed and I don't it may or
Caption: may not be an actual release depending
Caption: on how you term the word release because
Caption: people oh we do CD we do 200 releases a
Caption: date okay that's fine
Caption: but it's really a thing you can give a
Caption: customer to get some feedback right so
Caption: how Jeff so that this is something I
Caption: blogged from Jeff Patton I didn't before
Caption: this actually in his book and on his
Caption: website
Caption: the first thing you want to do is the
Caption: good enough so that might be your
Caption: skateboard and then you get some
Caption: feedback and then you make it better and
Caption: so forth and so on until you get to the
Caption: really best thing that you can do this
Caption: is a example doctrine a turd because I
Caption: went through all my photos and went
Caption: under if I have a real picture of
Caption: something we actually did so the
Caption: interesting thing here is that it
Caption: coincidentally fairly well resembles the
Caption: previous thing so this was for making
Caption: text digital we had a compliance goal
Caption: that we had to had to had to meet by
Caption: certain date so that was a very minimum
Caption: MVP what we ended up doing was in some
Caption: cases removing some of the bells and
Caption: whistles that had been in previous UK
Caption: tax fulfilment to really focus on that
Caption: goal and then we started adding things
Caption: back in and making it more and more
Caption: whiz-bang so by the time we got to the
Caption: bottom part it was the bells and
Caption: whistles or singing or dancing but if if
Caption: a deadline came and
Caption: all we'd done was the compliance goal we
Caption: were fine we could ship that and we
Caption: would know that we do at least met the
Caption: bare minimum for compliance so this is a
Caption: pretty high-level thing because our
Caption: board wasn't that big but yeah you can
Caption: see that we sort of followed that pretty
Caption: well so that was good who uses JIRA
Caption: pretty much yeah lots of people use JIRA
Caption: ok
Caption: again not being paid for this but there
Caption: is a third-party add-on with the really
Caption: snappy name of easy agile story map for
Caption: JIRA I don't know is anybody using this
Caption: if you're doing story mapping and you're
Caption: using JIRA it is not a free thing you
Caption: will have to pay for it but it's a
Caption: really really good idea because what we
Caption: found was when we started with the big
Caption: wall and put everything on there because
Caption: we were using JIRA for the day-to-day we
Caption: could mimic that giant wall in JIRA and
Caption: then it was so much easier to follow
Caption: along and keep things going in our
Caption: slices could then become related to
Caption: releases in JIRA and we could do sprints
Caption: within that and it just it was it was
Caption: really good
Caption: I was surprised yeah so also great for
Caption: people that work remotely because you
Caption: know I don't know if you've ever tried
Caption: to do a remote meeting where you're
Caption: trying to hold up somebody's machine so
Caption: they can see the physical board right
Caption: yeah you can't read what's on the card
Caption: but it's up there somewhere this is much
Caption: much better so if you are using JIRA +1
Caption: for this thing ok so now we've got our
Caption: map thinking about story points so I
Caption: don't know how many of you all have ever
Caption: been in a you know planning meeting
Caption: where you've spent way too much time
Caption: trying to decide if a story is a 3 or 5
Caption: and people will be having the heated
Caption: argument while everybody else is going
Caption: maybe this only happened to me I don't
Caption: know but again why why why are you doing
Caption: that and even worse that whole thing
Caption: where people go ok so that yeah that'll
Caption: take me a week so yeah that's a 5 and
Caption: and then you get to the other end where
Caption: somebody's going ok so that
Caption: 9 so that's what it'll take you two
Caption: weeks like why are you doing that why
Caption: would you take time to put it it's a
Caption: story points to then put it back at the
Caption: time and I mean this is the numbers
Caption: they're just Wow
Caption: why so I you know I I sort of question
Caption: this and it like heresy because we all
Caption: know that if you're agile you have tests
Caption: or points right you know and then I saw
Caption: this from Ron Jeffries and he said ah 1
Caption: 2 and she big odd days not points and I
Caption: went oh yeah that's cool that's kind of
Caption: what I think - you know this is how you
Caption: can size stories it takes one day takes
Caption: two days or it's too big break it down
Caption: if you don't know who Ron Jeffries is
Caption: he's the guy who invented story points
Caption: and he's been spending a lot of time
Caption: apologizing it for it since and for the
Caption: misuse of story points because the idea
Caption: was with the best of intentions it was
Caption: to stop people from being beaten by
Caption: saying you told me this would take two
Caption: days and it took four you know how dare
Caption: you um so they thought well how could
Caption: fool you it's that's not in days the
Caption: same points but everybody just
Caption: translates it so I thought okay I'm in
Caption: good company here if I'm questioning
Caption: this so my suggestion of something to
Caption: try is to break the work down into kind
Caption: of stories of the same size as best as
Caption: you can either using you know that one
Caption: to two big idea or no killings got
Caption: another one where he says each story
Caption: should fulfill one acceptance criterion
Caption: so if you're using acceptance criteria
Caption: try and make your story is the same size
Caption: and know you'll never get them all
Caption: exactly the same size but the idea is to
Caption: try and do that and if you can do that
Caption: then you can start just counting how
Caption: many you have instead of worrying about
Caption: how big each one is and then things get
Caption: easier and if you are using jira you can
Caption: configure it to use story counts instead
Caption: of story points or time woo so it's just
Caption: another level of simplification another
Caption: thing that I suggest everybody everybody
Caption: knows that we're agile so we measure
Caption: velocity okay that's nice but I think if
Caption: you look at lean theory the cycle time
Caption: and throughput are actually a little bit
Caption: more important so if you haven't heard
Caption: of these things before the cycle time is
Caption: how long it takes you to get from a
Caption: certain point in your process to a
Caption: certain other point so in software
Caption: development it's usually from you know
Caption: if you're doing this sort of board thing
Caption: you take it from the to-do pile and it's
Caption: in progress
Caption: all the way through until you know done
Caption: done or released or finished or whatever
Caption: you want to call the column on the end
Caption: and your throughput is how many now that
Caption: we're counting stories I can count how
Caption: many stories they did per iteration so
Caption: per sprint or per week or whatever
Caption: you're doing I had teams that were doing
Caption: Kanban that did by week or sprint we did
Caption: two weeks
Caption: yeah so if you're kind of looking at the
Caption: idea of these two things instead of
Caption: velocity the shortest cycle times are
Caption: likely to have higher throughput and
Caption: supposedly according to the Theory of
Caption: Constraints the best way to optimize is
Caption: to focus on your throughput so the idea
Caption: is to try and get this predictability of
Caption: pushing through the same number of
Caption: stories per iteration again if you're in
Caption: G roll and they call this the control
Caption: chart I don't know why but that's what
Caption: it's called
Caption: so if you're looking for cycle time it's
Caption: called control I guess they want to feel
Caption: like they're controlling but it's quite
Caption: an easy visual because if you're if your
Caption: cycle time is roughly the same for each
Caption: story these little green dots will be
Caption: closely together and that shaded area
Caption: will be thinner so you can just look at
Caption: this and go well they're really far
Caption: apart our stories aren't really equally
Caption: sized if they kind of close you think
Caption: yeah we're doing okay also I would
Caption: suggest that one week to do per story
Caption: might be a little bit big so you might
Caption: want to get it down to the one to two
Caption: days I think this is an example I just
Caption: flogged off with the JIRA website
Caption: nothing to do with anything I've ever
Caption: worked on mm-hmm so the next thing we
Caption: can look at is forecasting so once
Caption: you've started to become more
Caption: predictable you can then think more
Caption: about how your past performance can
Caption: indicate future so if you're in Brisbane
Caption: and at summer time for example the
Caption: chances yesterday was hot with a chance
Caption: of rain today will be higher with a
Caption: chance of rain tomorrow will also be hot
Caption: with a chance of rain because it's quite
Caption: predictable in Melbourne on the other
Caption: hand yet God knows you're on your own so
Caption: bearing in mind of course this is a
Caption: model all models are wrong that's
Caption: something useful there's a number of
Caption: different ways you can do this
Caption: forecasting so again our friend JIRA has
Caption: a burned-down thing which will tell you
Caption: again this is something I just took off
Caption: the bog standard Atlassian website based
Caption: on your velocity for the last three
Caption: sprints and will take you six more to
Caption: complete this epic yeah that's pretty
Caption: good
Caption: not bad but we can do better
Caption: so probabilistic forecasting is the
Caption: reason why if you if you look at your
Caption: weather app it doesn't tell you tomorrow
Caption: or rain it tells you 60% chance of rain
Caption: tomorrow so it's it's working something
Caption: out
Caption: based on probability in a forecasting
Caption: software world this is the idea of what
Caption: is the chance of finishing on or before
Caption: a certain date so how it works is you
Caption: look at what percentage of the possible
Caption: results were actually on or before that
Caption: date and then you can say oh we're 85%
Caption: sure we can deliver by the 17th of
Caption: August so that's the other good thing is
Caption: that probabilistic forecasting relies
Caption: upon the inputs to these sort of math
Caption: things being in exact which is great
Caption: because that's what we have and now here
Caption: it is the magic crystal ball so using
Caption: arthur c clarke third law of any
Caption: sufficiently advanced technology is
Caption: indistinguishable from magic
Caption: here is my crystal ball this link takes
Caption: you to a github repository that was put
Caption: out there by troy McGinnis who is
Caption: forever I am forever thankful because
Caption: he's got a bunch of spreadsheets that do
Caption: all the maths for you which is awesome
Caption: and the one I used as my magical
Caption: prognosticator is called the throughput
Caption: forecaster and what that is is an Excel
Caption: spreadsheet that does a whole bunch of
Caption: things some of them are the same things
Caption: that you can do in JIRA which is good if
Caption: you don't have jury you can use this and
Caption: if you do you can be even lazier and not
Caption: use it and take the numbers right out of
Caption: JIRA and so how it worked is and this is
Caption: an example so the sheet has a whole
Caption: bunch of instructions in it that I
Caption: didn't show because it's fine print but
Caption: basically to show you how little the
Caption: work is put in a date how many stories
Caption: are remaining to be completed so you can
Caption: take it and I like how it says guests so
Caption: one of the team's I was working with did
Caption: a t-shirt size small medium large and so
Caption: they balanced it out depending on how
Caption: many stories they thought something
Caption: breakdown into so a large at the low
Caption: might be oh yeah we might break this up
Caption: into three stories a medium might be
Caption: that could be a 2 A 1 a small would be 1
Caption: & 4 a high guess we did 5 3 1 or you
Caption: could just put in a bit more of a guess
Caption: II guess and then there's a guess what
Caption: your split rate is so another team I
Caption: worked with had had that where we
Caption: started out going we've got no idea
Caption: let's just say every story we have is
Caption: going to turn into two stories when we
Caption: start looking at it a little bit more
Caption: and then we realized all that was that
Caption: was way off okay we need to get down a
Caption: little bit closer so we ended up with I
Caption: think every story breaking up into 1.25
Caption: then you tell it how many weeks or what
Caption: your cycle is so this was the Kanban one
Caption: one week if you were doing sprints it'd
Caption: be two weeks and then if you have got
Caption: your historical data so how many stories
Caption: you completed per iteration if you have
Caption: at least seven weeks worth of that then
Caption: that goes in a sheet as well which is so
Caption: boring I'm not even going to show you
Caption: because it's literally a column with
Caption: number of stories completed in each cell
Caption: going back historically and if you do
Caption: that you have data if you don't have
Caption: that like if you're just starting out
Caption: with a new team have a guess here's your
Caption: locus here's your I guess that's all you
Caption: need to do and then whoa it produces
Caption: this wonderful red and the green
Caption: delightful chart guaranteed to please
Caption: managers everywhere so what is this
Caption: witchcraft it's actually running a Monte
Caption: Carlo simulator behind the scenes with
Caption: no work on my part
Caption: yes using statistics and probability to
Caption: help visualize the potential outcomes so
Caption: in this case the simulator is
Caption: forecasting how long it will take to
Caption: complete the features that we've told it
Caption: we have based on the data that I entered
Caption: so strenuously in the previous screen so
Caption: using this information that
Caption: hypothetically completes the work 500
Caption: times and then shows you the likelihood
Caption: of it finishing by date and in the
Caption: spreadsheet itself it shows you all
Caption: kinds of whiz-bang graphs about how it
Caption: was doing that and I went that's nice I
Caption: don't really need to know how you came
Caption: up with the numbers because this is
Caption: awesome
Caption: and after we used it a few times and
Caption: found out that I was actually a
Caption: reasonably good indicator people started
Caption: having a bit more trust in it and it
Caption: became my magical crystal ball
Caption: prognosticator which was so valuable for
Caption: such little effort like I just took some
Caption: numbers that we already had in JIRA and
Caption: entered them in a spreadsheet and it did
Caption: it all the mess for me so what we ended
Caption: up doing was creating estimates for
Caption: confidence as well as time so again
Caption: something Jeff Patton talks about is
Caption: what's your bet level what would you bet
Caption: would you bet your house that you're
Caption: going to be finished would you bet your
Caption: lunch you know how does that fit into
Caption: this you know and it's red yellow and
Caption: green which management love okay so this
Caption: is Troy McGinnis he's the person who set
Caption: this up and as he says forecasting is
Caption: about answering questions to a
Caption: transparent degree of certainty with as
Caption: little effort as possible so he has made
Caption: that effortless so it's simple
Caption: transparent and provides an indicator of
Caption: our predictability thanks Troy you're
Caption: awesome
Caption: okay so the TLDR
Caption: deadlines happen try spending less time
Caption: estimating not more use story mapping
Caption: even in JIRA to help break up and
Caption: visualize your work try using story
Caption: counts instead of story points and just
Caption: rule just reduces the the level of
Caption: cognitive challenge that you're dealing
Caption: with not code focus more on throughput
Caption: in cycle time and less on velocity and
Caption: then try the throughput forecaster to
Caption: estimate confidence as well as time my
Caption: disclaimer is that these are some other
Caption: things that we tried and they actually
Caption: worked
Caption: but everything's in context so please
Caption: don't do the whole Spotify model thing I
Caption: went to this conference and I was told
Caption: I'm not agile unless I'm I stopped using
Caption: story points yep no don't have to do
Caption: that what my goal was and this talk is
Caption: to give you a few ideas and maybe
Caption: hopefully some things you haven't seen
Caption: before that you can try with your teams
Caption: please do inspect in adapt and if you
Caption: want to know more about how to manage
Caption: your work in an agile way while still
Caption: dealing with this when will it be done
Caption: yet is it done is it done how about now
Caption: there are books and blog posts done by
Caption: these people
Caption: Jeff patent troll McGinnis Ron Jeffries
Caption: Neil Killick Mary and Tom poppendieck
Caption: Boyko adzick and Jonah Rothman and
Caption: probably some more but these were just
Caption: the people whose work I use putting this
Caption: talk together and yep done so I'm hoping
Caption: I've still left some time for questions
Caption: of time Oh loads of time but we can't do
Caption: questions until my Mike's been turned on
Caption: is it done yet yeah cause like a true
Caption: Pro anyone go to precious Roy you found
Caption: the button that's going all right thanks
Caption: for sure listen